and welcome to this special edition of
Hannity the Biden family scandals
tonight for the hour we will explore
every dark corner of this family's
Decades of disgrace allegations of
influence peddling public corruption
bribery money laundering tax evasion gun
crimes drug crimes prostitution and a
four-year-old little girl that no one in
the entire family wants to claim and
make no mistake the bidens would be
great on an episode of The Jerry
Springer Show but they are totally unfit
for the White House Now needless to say
there is a lot to unpack so let's begin
with the big guy himself that guy right
there your President Joe Biden how did
he become so rich after decades as being
a public servant he has two massive
houses one right there and a beautiful
beach he has that classic Corvette we
all know about a net worth of around 10
million dollars so how did this happen
on a meager government salary did Joe
profit from his son Shady internet
National Business deals now based on
texts and emails from Hunter's laptop
from Hell while there is evidence that
appears to show that Hunter complained
bitterly about having to hand over half
his salary to quote pops even paid for
Joe's upkeep at his mansion and repairs
he hated it there was also one email
that discussed a 10 payout to the big
guy held by Hunter that is likely just
the tip of the iceberg now according to
an ongoing investigation from the house
oversight committee there are over 20
shell companies we learned about this
week mostly formed during Biden's time
as VP and they were used to covertly
distribute quote over 10 million dollars
from foreign Nationals to Biden family
and friends now we're talking about
Hunter Biden Jim Biden Jim Biden's wife
Hunter Biden's girlfriend Hunter Biden's
ex-wife Hunter Biden's current wife and
three of Joe Biden's grandchildren
wonder what the grand children did for
the money anyway why were all of these
bidens allegedly now receiving payments
from foreign Nationals funneled through
multiple show corporations as James
Comer is claiming for example money from
a Chinese State Energy company was
allegedly filtered through five llc's
before winding up in the hands of four
different Biden family members sounds a
little sketchy doesn't it and it was not
just China was it take a look
Hunter Biden and his associates
capitalized on a lucrative Financial
relationship with the Romanian National
who was under investigation for and
later convicted of corruption in Romania
the bidens received over one million
dollars for the deal
and 16 of the 17 payments to their
Associate's account that funneled the
Biden's money occurred while Joe Biden
was vice president
in fact the money stops flowing from the
Romanian National soon after Joe Biden
leaves the vice presidency
this is a pattern of influence peddling
now according to a report from
foxnews.com the proceeds from this
Romanian deal were discussed during
Hunter Biden's 2016 divorce now honest
question what were these foreign
Nationals what were they expecting in
exchange for these payments what were
they trying to buy what was the
expectation why was the money spread out
across the entire Biden family after
getting funneled through llc's that many
call Shell corporations now at the very
least the appearance of impropriety is
off the charts but the Biden White House
they refused to answer any and all
questions about the Shady family
business and now voters they are deeply
concerned take a look at this
I'm really just disappointed that uh
politicians continue to come into office
and leave extremely richer it's
completely unethical I mean you have
foreign Nationals funneling money into
an LLC then being disbursed to the fight
the Biden family
um I mean it's basically unethical it's
a national security threat it could be
treasonous as far as I'm concerned I
don't think that you rise to that level
of power without having skeletons in
your closet on either side but why is
America okay why is that an okay
narrative that we just get to go along
with that oh this person's corrupt we're
going to spend taxpayer dollars to
investigate them and nothing's going to
change all right so there is a
documented web of suspicious activity
International payments and at least one
whistleblower allegation that is
accusing Biden himself a bribery there
are also Witnesses like former Hunter
business partner Tony bobolinski
detailing Biden's public corruption and
of course we can't forget about all of
that evidence on Hunter's laptop from
Hell a laptop top that according to John
Solomon that the FBI had in December of
2019 and verified by the spring of 2020.
so my question tonight is this what is
going on at the doj do they exist merely
to protect Democrats and hurt
Republicans do we have a two-tier
justice system do they care about
Justice or the rule of law at all is
there equal application of our laws is
there Equal justice under the law hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else